more on our Fox News Alert Massachusetts  senator Elizabeth Warren just confirming  moments ago her older brother has died  after contracting the corona virus the  senator says on Twitter quote ungrateful  to the nurses and frontline staff of  took care of them but it's hard to know  that there was no family to hold his  hand or to say I love you one more time  no funeral for those of us who loved him  to hold each other close  I'll miss you dearly my brother senator  Warren tweets and Sandra it's just so  tragic and sad she goes on to talk about  her brother Dan joining the Air Force at  the age of 19 he served this country and  now dies of coronavirus without any  family there yeah 20 year veteran of the  US Air Force so we thanked him for his  service and our condolences to Elizabeth  Warren and her family this morning  absolutely